thanks so much everyone for coming
welcome to PI data this is actually my
first time here so it's a completely new
experience for me how I'm going to be
talking about pandas today how many
people in here have heard of it
okay how many of you have used it
alright then this might be you guys
might teach me something at some point
how many of you have heard a sequel to
and like use that a lot of you okay so
my background is I learned databases
very early on like when I was started
working with computers but I never
really had like a true data structures
and algorithms course so I use sequel a
ton and I thought in these kind of like
tabular structures and when I was first
learning pandas about two years ago
there was no good way of kind of
approaching pandas from a sequal
perspective because that's what I knew
and that's kind of the viewpoint I
wanted to approach things with so I
wrote a long blog post which has now
morphed into this talk give me a tabular
structure don't give me like weird
nested JSON data structures because they
can be goofy to work with so the goal of
my talk today is to give everyone a
foundation for pandas definitely going
to take like a wide and shallow approach
and I think it's kind of good that this
is one of the first talks of the
conference because I'm sure a lot of
other talks will kind of talk about
pandas so it'll be a good reference
point I want to emphasize that this is a
tutorial actually and not a talk so I'll
be talking a ton but if people have
questions throughout feel free to
interject and I will happy to be happy
to continue that conversation I'm
actually not sure why I wrote end back
either because if you can translate
something one way you can kind of
translate it the other so I'm Greg if
that cartoon looks familiar
that means you've probably wound up on
my blog for some reason or you've been
ordering GrubHub which is actually where
I used to work so like I mentioned my
background isn't a true computer science
or engineering I actually studied
economics in college so I think in terms
of like data analysis and all that and
so my background I love the data to
micro pub for three years and
I recently joined a company called data
scope analytics where I'm a data
scientist data scope this is my one data
scope spheal slide we kind of work at
this weird intersection between like
data science design and strategy
consulting we take a humor human
centered approach to data science so
step one is always making sure we're
actually working on the right problem
and we use a ton of Python pandas so
started in 2008 by Wes McKinney is when
development started he was actually
working at a hedge fund or at an
investment firm here in New York and
actually convinced them to open-source
it so good job investment firm what his
goal was with the project was to make
Python great for data analysis it at the
time if you think about it like a lot of
people were using sequel using are using
Python Python now we kind of have this
one language that we can be productive
in quickly if we want to do data things
and what it actually is is I like to
think it was a nice human centered
wrapper around numpy so numpy can be a
little bit tough to work with times and
a little bit unintuitive pandas makes
numpy really nice there's a huge active
community too which is really awesome
it's actually led by Geoffrey Beck now
Wes has his company was acquired by
cloud era so he's working for them but
Geoffrey Beck is actually speaking here
tomorrow at 1:30 I think and he's going
to be talking about new features that
have been in the most recent release of
pandas but the community is awesome
I've actually contributed to pandas
there are 300 contributors and there's I
had never contributed to open-source
before so pandas is really nice in the
sense that and the documentation pages
there's a whole section that's just
here's how you contribute to pandas so
it gives you the process how to work
with the contributors it's it's a lot of
fun super easy and that book is actually
a book Wes wrote about two years ago
that covers pandas in depth I'd highly
recommend it if any of you leave here
today and kind of want to know more
about about pandas so I searched for a
data janitor and this is kind of what
came up I thought I was I thought it was
a funny picture I think the cool thing
about it too is that art
our janitor actually looked like he just
came from a graduation but so this is
the problem that the pen is set out to
solve data is kind of crappy it's never
just right it's like a it's like a
Goldilocks problem you're always trying
to like lunge something into like this
nice little perfect form where all of
your data types are clean you're not
mixing strings with integers or whatever
but something's always mildly off and
the old workflow at least for me about
two years ago was you know all of my
data was in a database scrap hubs a web
app so we're on top of my sequel so I'd
be writing sequel tons of it rolling
data up as necessary then I'd pull it
into Python and I'd kind of like munge
it a little bit more and then I
eventually I'd pull it into our to do
some sort of modeling or data
visualization because our ggplot and
ggplot was awesome but there's a high
cognitive cost to that like I'm not
kidding when I actually say I found
myself writing sequel or Python in my
our studio so I can kind of get
confusing so pendous solves this problem
it allows you to stay productive in the
one language and to kind of work
throughout your flow with without a high
cognitive cost without that switching
cost that you had before and one of the
big things about pandas is that it lets
you focus on exploring so we kind of
have all my slides just drop so we kind
of have all these like pandas astronaut
explorers that are that want to answer
questions about space and pandas let's
you get into to answering questions and
right and so it has that low switching
cost and I think that's one of the great
things about sequel especially if you
have data in the database
sequels great at lot at allowing you to
answer questions quickly it's it's super
high level it's very intuitive
oftentimes it's like you're speaking in
like English right it's like take these
tables show me these things from it
where this condition isn't true Python
was lacking that and the issue I had
with our and I think a lot of people had
with it is that our could be a little
bit too forgiving at times the syntax
was is kind of weird but
at the same time you'd read data in or
you'd do some sort of transformation on
that data thinking it like it'll run and
you thought what you just did was
correct but in reality you realize ten
steps down the line that something was
off about it and the nice thing about
Python and pandas in particular so pen
is very expressive it's very easy to
read and understand and pythons whole
motto of there's only one way to do it
it kind of it removes that problem of
silent errors if it's going to fail it's
going to fail very loudly and it's going
to fail early so meaning you're not
going to get 10 steps through your
analysis and realize my whole
transformation was just off so another
thing about pandas is that it's it's
kind of a PI data glue language it data
frames which is one of the main
structures of pandas data frames work
very nicely with things like
scikit-learn stats models Seabourn
matplotlib it's very easy to kind of
just take it and call it plot method and
all of a sudden you now have this nice
plot we have the good thing about pandas
that kind of connects to every sort of
any sort of data source you can imagine
so you can hook into sequel database
flat files excel you name it it's in
there it's a great PI data foundation
the one thing pandas isn't is it's not a
database actually so Wes gave a talk
here last year and this was one of the
things that he emphasized a lot is that
it's not a database it's not tightly
coupled with the database I think the
quote he used was it's too far away from
the metal and the problem with that is
that you know pend is great for
in-memory analytics but when you're
working on these massive data sets at
times you can't you can't suck a hundred
million record file into into memory you
can but your computer is probably going
to grind to a halt pretty quickly and
the thing about pandas is that when you
actually hook into a database the
database reader methods are a little bit
memory intensive and can kind of slow
you down you know some of the other
things you said with that group buys and
joins aren't what they could be in
pandas and you don't those are things
that a database is made for it that's
that's what sequel is great for so one
of the things that I hope to like have
you guys take away from today is that
pandas is great for a lot of things
but in some ways databases are pretty
fantastic at doing these groupings
joining operations and if possible in
your analysis you should push that sort
of work on to the database and then
bring it into pandas and that's that's
the approach I tend to take in my work
you know pandas isn't necessarily going
to be able to compete with something
like an Amazon redshift right now and if
anyone doesn't know a redshift I'm happy
to talk about it after the talk but it's
pretty amazing
so here's what we're going to cover
today we're going to cover data
structures series data frames I'm going
to talk about indexes briefly but the
main thing that I think I'm going to
want you guys to take away is just that
indexes aren't columns they look like
columns and data frames but they're not
and if you try to treat them like a
column it's not going to work what's
over to go through selecting joining
grouping filtering all that kind of
stuff and then I'm going to be trying to
use sequel like keywords throughout but
if I don't and need to clarify some
things
feel free to speak up someone asked me I
get actually gave this talk at a meet-up
in Chicago on Thursday night and someone
asked me if I was going to cover pandas
sequel in depth so there's a library
called panda sequel that I think the
guys at y-hat wrote that allows you to
write sequel against your data frames
and while that's awesome I'm not going
to cover it only because the top of the
goal of the talk is to translate sequel
to pandas not rights equal in pandas
that make sense there's also a ton of
time story stuff in pandas I'm going to
talk a little bit about it but if you
tend to work with a lot of time series
data I would say explore the
documentation a bit more because there
is so much functionality there that you
couldn't even cover it in an hour long
talk and then at the end I'm going to
get into some applied analysis using
ipython notebook I'm going to be working
with the divi data set and what Divi is
is it's like trick data like rental bike
data throughout throughout Chicago I
think here you guys call it city bike so
the first data structure so one it's
it's the series which is a
one-dimensional kind of structure it's a
heterogeneous object and it's kind of
like a list so if you can see in this
top line
we're create
series bypassing it a list actually so
seven so an integer string we're passing
a float they're a large integer integer
and then another string and we kind of
get this object with with our values in
a column so a series is actually very
similar to a column in a database or in
arts it's called a vector and if you
notice along the left side there's kind
of that zero one two three four that's
our index because we didn't pass an
index an explicit index two to the
series constructor we're seeing pandas
automatically adds an auto increment
integer for us as the index if you
actually look below though so we're
passing a dictionary now we're passing
Chicago like various cities as the keys
and then arbitrary numbers as the values
of those cities and because the series
constructor knows how to take a
dictionary and use the keys as the index
once you call once you pass it to the
constructor we now have this kind of
this nice list where our indexes are
actually kind of metadata about the
series
it makes for nice data alignment and to
kind of keep a little bit more
information about your records anyone
that makes sense everyone cool so series
slicing like with getting objects out of
a series it's very similar to getting
objects out of out of a list in the
sense that you can actually just use
standard Python slicing so if you see in
the top the top image we're selecting
the second and third records of the
series so much like Python slicing it
goes up to the last value so we're only
getting Chicago in New York here but
because we also passed in that nice
index and actually any index we pass
into a series or any index on a series
we can just take cities and then put
square brackets around it and give it
the index label and it will give us back
that value so if if that index label was
actually that auto increment we would
just pass in a zero there and it'd still
give us that value you can also get
values out of a series using boolean
slicing and what boolean slicing is is
within the square brackets you pass in
some sort of condition so this
is kind of like your where clause in
sequel and that condition actually
filters down the series to the objects
that you care about so here we're saying
show me the cities where the value that
they had was greater than a thousand and
we only get New York in San Francisco
here and lastly we could actually do
boolean slicing series themselves have a
lot of methods so in the case if you
actually remember back when we created
this series you can see Boston has none
so impended that's going to be it's it's
called na n and numpy I think it's na n
sequel it's essentially during a null
value so Amanda's you actually can just
say cities where the cities is null and
that's why we get Boston so you could
actually do some basic operations on
Ceres too so if you see in that first
record we're actually changing the
values of the series
so we're saying show me all the serie
all the cities where the value is less
than a thousand and change it to 750 and
then if we look at the series we can see
that Austin in Portland where the two
that were less than a thousand and they
now have the 750 value you can apply
arbitrary math upon series so here we're
saying take every series after the every
item after the third value in the series
and add 7 to it so now you see Boston or
sorry New York Portland and San
Francisco have all had some basic math
done to them the last one can be a
little bit weird can throw you for a
loop at times I know it has for me so
when you're mapping a series if you're
mapping two series together what ends up
happening is that they are but they join
on the index so if there are index
values that are not shared between the
two series the operation that you just
try to perform will return a null object
so if you can see in that in that last
example the only item that's actually
since we're slicing this the city series
the only the only city that's actually
shared between the two is Chicago so all
of the other cities because when you get
a none because when you add none to a
value it returns none right so the
absence of a value
can never create another value make
sense okay cool
data frames so that's one like the other
main structure that pandas introduces
and a data frame you can think of it as
an our data frame or you can actually
also think of it as a table in a
database so you can create it many ways
here I'm just passing a list of
dictionaries to the data frame
constructor and I'm actually specifying
that my columns and the like the
ordering I want my columns in so
actually if I wouldn't have passed that
columns parameter my columns would have
been ordered alphabetically and that's
so in regards to that parameter that's
that's another big thing about pandas is
that every method and every kind of
function that's in there has a wealth of
parameters that I invite everyone to
explore we'll talk a lot about them
especially when you get into the reader
methods pandas has thought the
developers have thought through a ton of
different ways and a ton of different
issues that you might run into when
reading data into the library so back to
the data frame though so here's kind of
just this arbitrary way you call a list
of dictionaries and all of a sudden you
know you now have this nice tabular
structure obviously a lot of times
you're going to be reading data in from
various files or databases or maybe even
api's but I found that this constructor
is really a nice way to kind of get
moving on a data frame just because
often I'm scraping
I don't know NBA data or baseball data
or something like that and I usually
have my methods return a list of
dictionaries like this so it's nice to
when I want to go to my analysis just
past that method to the data frame
constructor and get going on it
another big thing too about data frames
is that you can actually think of them
as a group of series that share of one
Access or a group of series that share
an index I'm sorry and data frames
actually have two indexes or indices
along the top you have the columns
obviously but that's an index and that's
actually also called an axis in some
parts so it's a two
a dataframe is a to index to access
object and the top the top index is
access zero and the one along the along
the bottom along the side is access one
so main thing to just take away there
that column headers are an index of
themselves because you can kind of just
tilt a data frame arbitrarily does that
make sense okay cool
I'll explain it a bit in the later a bit
later so yeah like I mentioned I gave
this talk on on Friday or I'm sorry on
Thursday actually in Chicago they were
kind of like my guinea pigs and I had a
lot of stuff on this slide about indexes
but ultimately I decided to delete it
all and just say they're not columns
because that's all you should take away
from right now you can think of an index
like a primary key column but the weird
thing is that like with a primary key in
a database you can just select it
normally right like you could say where
this condition is met on the primary key
you can join on primary keys all this
kind of stuff in pandas if you want to
if you want to select from like using
the index values there are different
methods now and if you want to join
using index values you have to specify
different parameters of the joint
functions so the bait the main thing to
take away is that at least for me when I
was first learning panas indexes were
probably my biggest source of confusion
so just take away that they're not
columns and if you run into an error
because you're like you're trying to do
something on an index there's probably a
different method that you should
actually be using or you can just change
the index which we'll talk about - there
may the main goal of indexes are to
maintain the structure of the data frame
provide metadata so like we saw in
that's it in that cities example we're
providing some information about about
the other objects and for data alignment
so you can actually like look at your
data frame in a nice structured way so
demo time now so now we're going to move
to the the ipython notebook I think some
of you might have just come in recently
so if you want
I have an iPod on the the notebook is on
my github if you guys want to clone it
it's just GJ Rita hat and then slash hi
data 2014 NYC it seems like some of your
going to do that so I'm going to wait a
little bit or if you guys want to fire
up ipython notebook I think all of you
are using the anaconda install maybe I'm
not super familiar with how to load this
via in anaconda install or like how to
start the in akanda environment but so
what you could actually end up what you
do from the command line to fire up by
path on notebook is just type ipython
notebook in the directory that you want
to launch it in and it'll kind of load
up all the files necessarily so if we
were to do this here it brings us to the
page we go to demo GJ our EDA I probably
should have made like a bitly link or
something so that was a bit easier but
I think the Wi-Fi network here is we
work if anyone has having problems with
that there's an open network are people
still getting it okay I'm gonna get into
the demo then it seems like most people
have it who want so is anyone here
actually not familiar with ipython
notebook so everyone has used this
before like knows about it okay cool
then I don't need to talk about it so
standard ipython notebook stuff we're
loading our libraries and we're saying
we want to use MATLAB in line can
everyone see this okay to actually for
the most part yeah okay and I'm going to
hide this header to Russia gonna okay so
loading everything so imagine we have a
CSV file that we want to read into
pandas pennants so pennis has a lot of
different ways to read from files and it
can read from almost any type of file
you can imagine but here we're going to
read in a basic CSV file for you New
Yorkers we're going to read in Mariano
Rivera's statistics over the course of
his career so you know it in that and
that repo you just downloaded there's a
directory called data and there's a file
called Mariano Rivera dot CSV you
obviously pass the string of the file
name to the read CSV method and now all
of a sudden we have this nice data frame
structure so I didn't run the top so we
have this nice data frame structure and
there are various methods that like I
mentioned pandas the developers have
thought very very very deeply about
reading your data in and any sort of
problems that you could run into during
that so since most of you are familiar
with ipython notebook you can actually
just go in the function and type
shift-tab and all of a sudden you see
the parameters
that they've thought deeply about so we
can change the separator is there file
compression so maybe it's a zipped file
we can convert various objects on the
fly as we're reading it in are thousands
fields delimited with a comma so the
read CSB method you know if you're
running into issues check out the
parameters because there's typically a
lot of stuff in there that can already
help you you don't necessarily need to
write crazy unix commands to grip out
fields or find and replace using said
because most of it'll be here for you
already so it's kind of reading csv into
a data frame but one of the nice things
about pandas too is that you could
actually just fetch from a URL so if you
look at this URL it's pointing back to a
different directory my git repository so
we'll go take a look at it just so you
guys can see i'm in chrome so what this
actually is is a magazine in chicago did
an article that was the best sandwiches
in chicago but every sandwiches was on a
different page so I kind of got annoyed
and just scraped it all and put it in a
CSV so you can just see it's a tab
separated file here and it's a URL we
can go to Japan des and actually just
pass this URL to the read table method
and what it's going to do is pandas
knows to go out and fetch that object
and it'll try to read it in so here
we're saying here's the source of this
information is actually the URL variable
I gave you separated by tabs and then
here's a little wonkiness at the top
we're actually using this converters
parameter to convert the price on the
fly so if we look at the source data
there's actually let me find one here
and I'll highlight it so right here if
we see this 950 there's a dollar value
in it and actually all of the not the
decimal values so 950 750 whatever have
two periods so it ends with a period and
then obviously we want to keep the one
to separate the cents when we're reading
our data and we don't want this to be
read in as a string because that's
obviously we're not going to treat it
like it's a string maybe we want to
sumit or take the average price
something like that so we're going to
convert it on the fly as we're reading
it in so here I'm writing an arbitrary
function to find and replace all that
access stuff that we don't want and I'm
using a lambda function it does is
anyone not familiar with lambda
functions okay so we're getting a couple
a couple hands so what a lambda function
is in Python is it's just kind of like
this function that you're able to throw
away it's it's someone can probably
explain it better than I can here but so
instead of going through the standard
syntax so that function is actually the
same we'll talk about this piece of the
function sorry the like the first
section of it is actually the same as if
we were to say declare a function called
clean and say we're going to return
return s dot replace dollar and this is
hang on this is if there's no period it
will if there's a period in the price
right in S we return this and we're
going to leave off the last value
because we know that's where that extra
period is so otherwise return I don't
need this else but so this lambda
function here it's kind of ugly I
probably should just split this up to
make it clear is exactly the same as
writing the function in this way the
lambda function is just kind of like
it's an anonymous function you can use
it once and then it's kind of there but
here we're actually storing a function
in a bear in a variable because python
is kind of functions are first class
objects there so exactly the same so
what's actually happening is when we
read this in we're applying that lambda
function and we're like I'm creating
another one here because I want to
convert the object to a float on the fly
so as pandas is reading this we're
convert we're cleaning up the the each
very each of the each instance of the
price and we're also converting it to a
float at the same time does that make
sense okay cool
and then here's kind of what our data
looks like and you can see the price is
this nice field now where it's good
decimal amounts pandas can also read
from Jason so here I'm actually hitting
the github API for some pandas for some
issues in the the pandas repository and
you can just pass it so we'll look at
the the JSON it's it's not the right
thing it's just ugly
Jason structure and it's nested but so
what you could actually do is just say
hey pandas go get the this JSON object
at at this URL and then we read in a
data frame for us so you can see here
we're selecting just the body that they
created update the title and the URL
from that data frame and I'll actually
I'll get into this a little bit more
when I talk about select like how you
select from a data frame in a similar
way to how you select from from a sequel
table you might need to do some parsing
actually though when you read in from a
data frame and the reason using the read
jason method is and the reason for that
is is that like I mentioned data frames
can store any sort of it's a
heterogeneous object so it can actually
a a cell in a data frame can actually
store another JSON object and if you
think about like data frames are kind of
like this relational structure a lot
almost like sequel and you might in
Jason isn't relational it's nested so
you might need to parse out additional
things from a column does that make
sense okay cool this is actually
probably one of my favorite things about
pandas is there's this read clipboard
method a lot of times I might be writing
sequel and then I just want my data in a
data frame very quickly so we'll
actually use this raw data again so if I
just highlight it and ctrl C and I go
back to the demo and hit ctrl now we
have the data
in the data frame again so it's a really
quick and easy way to get your data into
a data frame a lot of times you know I
use various like sequel editors and I'll
have my data right there in a nice
tabular structure instead of going to
read it in I'll just copy it to the
clipboard and then read it in but you
can actually also hook into a sequel
database just fine so here we're using
sequel Lite and you can actually just
create a connection and all you have to
do is pass the connection to the this
reads sequel parameter this reads sequel
function and then give it the query and
you'll have your your data into a nice a
nice object a nice data frame here and
here's another example where we're kind
of converting things on the fly knowing
that the data in the sequel Lite
database isn't a nice it's it's text the
date is text it's not actually a nice
date time we can convert it on the fly
as we're reading it in so we're saying
take the date column and here's actually
the the structure of the date here's
what it looks like and this is using
standard Python date conversion
parameters that make sense yes okay so
I'm going to read this in because we're
actually gonna be using this a bit more
now so yes Oh so shift-enter will run
the cell and create a new and move to
the new one right below it
control-enter we'll run the cell and
just keep you in that current cell so
that makes it so I'll mostly use in
shift under so here I kind of talked
about how you could just use the
standard Python slicing to to kind of
inspect your data with with a series you
can do the same thing on a data frame so
you know here we're actually looking at
the hundreth record to the hundred and
fift record standard python slicing type
of stuff but you can also use head and
tail and head will show you the first
five records of the data frame table
will show you the last five
by default okay
another good practice that I always kind
of have when I'm working with data
frames is as soon as I read something in
I use this toad I use the data frame the
dot info method and what dot info does
is it shows you a bunch of basic
information about your data frame so on
the left side you can see actually the
columns in the middle you can see the
number of columns that are not the
number of values in those columns that
are not know and then the also the data
type of those columns so if we actually
see we kind of have a problem here in
this data set because the model were
empty strings it pandas we didn't
convert on the fly to a null object so
pandas you know an empty string is a
value so pandas thinks that you know
those are actually values so here it's
this you kind of need to look at these
sorts of things to make sure you're
you're catching everything but if we
actually look at this the Mariano Rivera
dataset we had from earlier we can see
there's an instance here at the but we
use dot info on it we can see if there's
an instance here at the bottom where you
know there were four years in the data
set where he didn't win some sort of
award make sense okay the other nice
thing too about inspecting your data is
there's a describe method and what
describe does is for any numeric field
it's actually going to it's going to
give you various basic statistics about
that numeric field so you can see you
know there were not the the winds column
was populated the winds field is
populated nineteen times and he averaged
four point three winds over the course
of his career with standard deviation of
two point zero eight
of three to six make sense the the one
thing you have to be compared you of
when using the subscribe method is like
I said it works on any integer field or
any numeric field so if you've like
right in a user ID obviously statistics
about a user ID are kind of irrelevant
so back to indexes and let's illustrate
how they're not columns so here with
that toad data set we're going to set
the index to date and we're setting it
in place and it's it's something I want
to point out is that a lot of a lot of
pandas methods will return a copy of the
data frame it won't actually modify the
data frame so you either have to do it
use this in place parameter which is
available on most most methods or catch
it in some way so if we weren't going to
sorry this just jump me all the way to
the top here if we weren't going to do
this in place we would have to delete
this and then catch it in like a random
object here but we'll modify it so now
if we actually look at our data frame if
you remember we had that random auto
increment index if we look at it here
you can see the date is now this index
along the left side this changes the way
now that we have to interact with that
date so now if we want to say let's say
we want to see all the towed vehicles
that were towed on November 4th of this
year if we run this we use this IX
method and we use square brackets if it
were a column we wouldn't actually be
doing this and I'll get into that later
so here dot IX I'm actually gonna remove
this because I didn't put limit 5 here
so that's actually what we're doing you
can see here are the various vehicles
that were towed on November 4th of this
year so again that's when you have an
index so you can use this dot IX method
if we actually wanted to see an
individual column while using that IX
method we can pass that same November
4th or whatever sort of index selection
we want to we want
select and then call that specific
column name so here we're selecting
vehicle we're selecting the make column
for all the vehicles that were towed on
November 4th and what actually happens
is we get a series back so this is a
nice series object if you're actually to
do type and like I mentioned you know a
data frame is a group of series you
actually see that this is actually a
series here now going back now let's say
we want to select the same nickels that
were towed on November 4th of this year
and that column is no longer in index so
here we're going to reset the index so
it's we're going to get back to that
auto increment we're going to do it in
place and so now I'll move this up here
to make this more clear so let's run
this now if we be toad head see we're
back to that old index right so crummy
index doesn't necessarily mean anything
and our dates just a column again now
again yes yes
yes yeah and I show something it can be
confusing that's that's why indexes or
not columns so you know we're selecting
we want let's say we want to see
vehicles where the dates November 4th to
2014 you know we get to this point again
where we can't use that dot IX method
anymore we have to say we have to pass
we have to use boolean slicing again so
what this is doing actually here is
saying this is making a series of
true/false values where the date is
November 4th 2014 and then it's passing
those true values to the data frame to
only return those objects to you so if
you to make that more clear I'll I'll
show this up at the top so so this is
how using the square bracket is how you
can select a column from a data frame
and we're applying a condition here now
so we're saying show me let's let's do a
comparison of the various values of the
date column to this standard string date
and what we get back false false false
false false let me make this do so
there's a method here called value
counts to show you guys that some of
these are actually true
see there's 70 of them that are actually
true ok so here all you're doing is
you're passing that list of true false
values to the data frame and it's
selecting the ones where where it's true
and so again now that it's not an index
anymore we have to treat it differently
okay that makes sense yes
warder minions by default yes what does
it do the one who makes from that
serious but for how it sorts yes it's
gonna use it from the dataframe order uh
okay sorry now I know what you're asking
this series on the dataframe are going
to be the same order because you're
selecting a column from I let's talk
about that after but it can be confusing
okay so moving on we can go to so now
like I mentioned you know when you make
selections if you want to see various
columns you can actually just hang on to
set this date index back so you can
actually set various columns that you
just want to see and all you actually do
there is you pass a list of the column
names to the data frame right so here
we're making a list and we we just want
to see the make color in the state we
pass that that list to the to the towed
vehicles data set makes sounds okay so
here we're just seeing the first five
and now back to the filtering like I
mentioned you know you can pass this
this series object of true/false values
to make your to do your filtering so
here we're going to say show me all the
towed vehicles where the make is forward
and then we're actually going to sort it
by state so we're applying now a little
bit more logic we're getting a little
bit more sequel about this and do it in
descending order and I think in most of
the cells I've tried to put the
equivalent sequel statements so you can
kind of compare them back and forth so
here you know selecting the ones that
are forward and we're sorting it by the
state so and since we're using the head
method we're saying show me the top five
and since we've sorted in descending
order you can see that these are towed
vehicles from Wisconsin to do and or
conditions now for filtering what you
actually end up having to do is you can
use the ampersand character for an and
and when you're doing multiple
conditions you have to pass them in
parenthesis so what actually ends up
happening
so here I'll run this and we can see
that it works
properly but if I were to actually take
these parentheses out we're going to get
an error because pandas doesn't know hot
like how to make the comparison
comparisons and it's going to say it
can't compare a scalar value it's right
here can't compare D type boolean array
to a scalar type right because what's
actually happening is it's trying to
compare like using the since it's a
string here it doesn't like it's
throwing it in does that make sense so
if we use an ampersand that's an and
condition now if we use a pipe that's
actually an or condition so here we're
saying show me all the towed vehicles
that were a Porsche or the state was New
York given that this is Chicago data
there aren't many New York towed
vehicles here so you can see here we
have some that are Porsche but these
other ones are actually in New York here
and then we're actually applying a
little bit more logic here so we're
sorting again but we want to sort by
multiple columns and when you want to do
things with multiple columns you're
almost always going to pass that pass a
list of those columns so here we're
saying sort apply make and model but
then are ascending values is we actually
want to sort we want the make to stay
sorted ascending and we want the the
color to sort descending and you could
act will actually see that the only one
that we are we could actually see
example of it is I think this portion I
left a comment here because it's hard to
find because there's only one yeah not
red Porsche hood so I can actually see
this red Porsche is actually sorted red
is the one that's appearing higher when
in reality it shouldn't if we were to
keep an ascending sort or a descending
sort yeah and so what we're actually
doing when we're passing these kind of
we can actually it's the same thing
we're creating those true false values
so we could actually create a filter
mask so we can say toad they're the
words of the styles of Ford or in the
state's Illinois
and we're going to store it in M so M is
now actually just the series again right
so say M value counts and we see that
there are twenty twenty-five twenty-six
hundred where it's true so now we can
just
that towed em we can pass that condition
the filter mask to the data frame and we
can actually say we'll actually only
show me these columns - so this will run
for us and we're selecting only a couple
columns because we're passing that list
of columns while also passing that
filter mass to filter our data for us
and then we're also applying a sort and
what's equivalent to a sequel limit does
that make sense yes yeah so so that
we're actually not passing the value
counts I'm only putting that there to
illustrate that there are some that are
true so because otherwise you might not
be able to see them so here if you were
actually just um it's that series of
true/false values again make sense okay
and so if anyone's ever worked with a
crummy database where you've potentially
had to find duplicates it can be a real
pain in the butt right especially if
primary keys aren't done like if if
three if they haven't if the database
hasn't been created in a very strict way
and somehow duplicates got in there and
your primary keys aren't really a unique
object you know you're grouping by tons
of columns you're getting counts and all
that kind of stuff Pano's has this
really nice way where it kind of just
murders sequel in that area toad has a
duplicated method so we could just say
show me all the toad objects they're
actually duplicated and then pass those
true/false that true/false series again
to the data frame we can see here are
some vehicles actually where they're
showing up twice in the data frame okay
so let's get to joining the only reason
so for those of you that might not be
familiar with ipython notebook all that
much you can actually execute arbitrary
command line arguments here so what I'm
actually doing is I'm grepping for
values where like a numeric field has a
column in the middle of it and the
reason is is that so the bike so this is
the divvy data now the bike trips if you
go over a thousand it starts turning
into a string now in our file so this is
going to be a pain in the butt to read
in so I just wanted to illustrate that
so here's where our two files look like
and then whether data which I actually
don't end up using but so now let's
read in this divvy data right so we're
going to create two new data frames
one's going to be trips and one's going
to be stations and they match up they
join to each other on the station name
but before I do that if we can see this
date format you know it's just a string
so we want to actually parse the date
properly so we can work with that so I'm
going to create another lambda function
that I'm going to call to date and all
I'm going to do is tell it how to parse
the date okay so we can read in the the
trips date of the CSV and using this
converters parameter we can say take the
start time and apply this to date
function and take the stop time and also
apply this to date function to it and
since like I mentioned earlier we know
that numeric field the thousands have a
comma in them we can say thousands it's
got a string there's a separator for
thousands that's a comma so it'll parse
that for us properly - so let me run the
cell so actually up a method and then
this will run it'll take a little bit to
run so Penn does actually if you notice
at the top earlier on when we were
parsing dates which file was it was with
this towed vehicles data set we used the
parse dates method you can actually use
that you can actually just give that I
won't go find it again the parse dates
method when you're reading data in you
can just give it true and it'll try to
parse every day yes
what's that okay so if you actually so
you can give that par States argument
just true and going to try to parse all
the dates for you however I'd advise you
that if you're working with a large file
and be explicit about parsing your dates
I actually found the other day that when
you're not explicit when you just give
it true and it tries to figure out the
date format for you it ends up taking
six or seven times more to read the data
in then what if you were to just
explicitly pass this data
yeah yeah Parr states are states will
handle it so the reason its lowers it's
because it's trying to a whole bunch of
different methods against it so now that
we've read our data in we can just look
at the data set and we can see that
using dot info we have seven hundred and
sixty thousand bike trips with various
metrics with various attributes about
about each trip and you can see that our
day time and that our date fields got
parsed in properly and everything else
kind of looks good here in the stations
set everything got read and find there
are 300 stations and those are going to
map so the thing that we need to note
here is that this from station name maps
to the name of the station and the to
station name also maps to the name of
the station because obviously each trip
has a has an origin and the destination
how many of you are familiar like it's I
think everyone here with familiar with
sequels everyone know joins how how
joins work in a database so basically
there I saw a couple like there
everything about a join is really yours
databases rely on kind of like working
in sets and set theory which is way out
of topic here but all you're doing is
you're taking two objects and you're
joining them together and what your it's
going to allow you to kind of like pull
in various pieces of information about
all so this is actually a really nice
graphic it's a Venn diagram showing you
the various joints of a database and how
actually they work in terms of sets so
here now that we know we need to join
the trips in the station's data so let's
say let's imagine we wanted to create a
map that is every trip that was taken
well that stations data has the latitude
and longitude the trips data doesn't so
we need to pull that latitude and
longitude into the trips data set so
here we're going to join the trips using
the merge function and we're going to
join it with stations and here we're
going to save the left joint the reason
we're using how left is because we want
to retain every trip so imagine there's
a scenario where you know some station
was actually there's a station that's
not in the station's data set we don't
want that trip to fall out we want to
keep that trip so we're saying get show
me all the trips and match it up with
the station but if it doesn't match to a
station I still want to keep it anyways
in the data set and we respect being
explicitly saying left on so the left
side left data frame we're saying join
it on the from station name on the right
we're going to join it to the name and
then if we look we're catch so we're
catching it in this divvy data set and
if we look we actually now have have our
data set with these new columns which
were the station's columns pulled in
right let's let's join it again because
we actually have to join it twice right
because we need to latitude for the
Fromm's for the origin station and we
need the latitude for the destination
station so we're going to join it again
here and we're going to actually take
the original the data frame that we just
created which we call divvy and join it
on the stations and here we're going to
say enter it really doesn't matter which
one I did here for the purposes of this
but it's just showing that you know if
you want to do a left join a right join
an inter join or even a full join and
this how parameter you just pass the
type that you want to do and here we're
going to say left on the two station now
right on the name and because we
actually already have the station this
similarly named columns on the data
frame we have that we're going to pass
in these suffixes so we want to label
that one one of the latitudes is the
origin and the other is the destination
if I didn't pass in the suffixes
arguments here panas would have just
named it
underscore accent underscore why to
allow us to differentiate but you can
actually be explicit about how you want
to name it so here if we look down now
we have these repeated columns but at
least one set is called origin and the
other set is called destination or dest
now talking another thing about sequel
right is you want to up sometimes you
want to Union tables together sometimes
they're partitioned or something like
that you just want to Union it together
so here I'm just showing how to do it
it's not it's actually something I don't
use too often in pandas but here we're
just creating two random data frames
with a bunch of random values we're
going to call them DF 1 and DF 2 and if
we we can go look at one of them just to
see what it's like we'd say there are
three values just arbitrary numbers and
all you actually have to use is this
concat method this can cat function so
you pass the list of your data frames
and it will concatenate them on access
zero remember so I talked about how the
headers are actually in index and there
are often called axes and the parameters
and the parameter arguments so it's
going to concatenate ax frame now where
a and B have kind of matched have joined
together and created a new data frame to
illustrate kind of what happened if we
were to actually call this C and
recreate this and we'll now let's see d
f2 is a and C if we were to run this
we're going to see that it created a new
column and because B didn't have a match
it's just going to create a new column
and shift them over and everything that
that didn't match up is going to get
nulls make sense the next thing about
this concatenated actually is because it
takes a list of arguments you can pass
multiple data frames to it so there have
been situations where I've been you know
scraping NBA data or something like that
and I have a series like I have I don't
know let's say a hundred data frames I
can just make a list of those data
frames and pass second cat now I have
one nice large object for me to work
with
yes it does work the same as append I
think the arguments are a little bit
different on them but they kind of
achieved the same things so one of the
weird things about pandas and it was
really a struggle for me to figure out
at first is that you don't loop in
pandas you can but it's not really a
great approach to it and can kind of be
a little bit confusing at times so what
you're actually doing is you're
vectorizing operations vectorization is
kind of a little bit out of scope for
this talk but it allows you to kind of
parallel eyes operations whereas looping
you're doing things sequentially and
procedurally if you vectorize it you can
apply it to a larger set in a quicker
amount of time so this is an example of
how you vectorize things it can be I'm
happy to talk a little bit more about it
after I just wanted to kind of get
across the point that you're not you're
not going to loop so in the Dubey data
set you know that the start time and the
stop time are precise to the minute what
if we didn't actually want that if we
wanted to let's say round it to the
nearest hour so 905 gets rounded to nine
o'clock so here we're going to create
this round time function and all this is
going to do is it's going to do a little
bit math and round our data to the
nearest hour for us and so you know the
old way of doing this or not necessarily
the old way but the looping way of doing
this was you iterate over every start
time you'd call this function maybe
you'd store it in a new list or actually
modified in place here you're not going
to loop your vectorizing the operation
so you're saying take the start time
series because with a column right
because every column is a series and
apply this round time function to it and
what we're doing here is we're actually
creating a new column that we're going
to call start our and the same thing
here we're going to call another column
called stop our make sense I'll show how
I'll show it just to kind of illustrate
it Divis know I didn't run the top parts
that
okay so here we'll go back and we'll run
this and what we're actually going to
end up seeing I guess I didn't even
really need to run it
but the start time here so if we look at
12:00 at 1211 it rounds to noon
12:55 runs to one o'clock kind of see
just you know if we were to want to plot
the data and it's precise to the minute
it can be very noisy and jittery and it
would be a little bit too much for us at
to see at one time so again you don't
really loop in panas you vectorize you
write a custom function and then you
apply it to either the entire data frame
or just to this series that you're
actually cared about and if you want to
store a new value you can just say it
equals this new column whatever you want
to name that new column so grouping in
pandas pandas draws largely from Hadley
wickham's split apply combined paper if
any of you are not familiar with Hadley
Wycombe
he is a develop an art developer
he's written a ton of packages for our
so if you've ever used art and worked
with ggplot plier D plier reshape
there's a whole bunch of them he's
written awesome stuff for ours and made
it a really great like data munging
language and he wrote this paper called
split apply combo the split apply
combined methodology for data analysis
and what it actually says it's a great
paper you should read it but it actually
really says is its it gives you a proach
to thinking about a data analysis and
often times you want to break things
down into smaller manageable pieces
apply some sort of function to each of
those pieces and then just combine it
back to one large frame so it's a while
it's it's definitely it's a little bit
it can be a technical paper because it
talks about one of his libraries at the
same time it's a great way to think
about how to approach an analysis and
that's kind of what I've found is that
the paper is just great for helping you
think so here's kind of what it looks
like so let's say we have this data
frame or this series where we have some
sort of key ABCD or ABC and a bunch of
numbers we're going to split it apart on
the key values apply a sum function and
then combine it back together and get
this smaller data frame that's actually
it's rolled everything up for us right
so it's similar to a group by if you've
ever done
a table a group by you've kind of worked
in the split of fly combine method
without really thinking about it it's
fairly intuitive so start trips by our
so let's say we wanted to say alright we
want to group our divvy data by that
start our that we created and we want to
see how many trips were taken in each of
those start ours so here we're going to
use the group by method against divvy
call the column we want and then apply a
size size method right so this is just
going to count the number of trips that
were taken there since our data frame is
all the trips so you can kind of see
this and what you actually get back here
and in this case is a series right so if
I were to run this see this we see this
our series and we again if we want to do
a type it's a series so when you're
using these group buys oftentimes you're
getting a series back so that's now
creating a new object that there are
additional methods available to if you
wanted so like in this one we can do
value counts actually and see actually
it's not going to work because the
number of trips
actually yeah we can value counts so you
can see okay there actually there there
are six start hours are sorry there are
68 start hours or there actually I got
to think about this there are there are
68 instances where there were six trips
taken in that start hour
okay makes sense but more so
illustrating the point that you get a
series back and how you can kind of do a
whole bunch of work on that series
actually if you were where to want to so
let's say we actually wanted to see the
start hour with the longest mean trip
duration so here we're going to group by
the start our again and we're going to
say we want to apply the mean function
to just this one column the trip
duration column because we want to see
the longest mean trip duration we're
going to order it in descending order
and then we're just going to look at the
top five right so here's what this would
look like in sequel were grouping
applying it to the column and then we're
sorting we get you know okay so June
27th at 1:00 a.m. the mean trip duration
was
31,000 seconds I don't know what
happened someone probably was just drunk
and forgot to return their bike or
something
but so again just showing a little bit
more group I enough if we wanted to
actually apply a function to multiple a
function of multiple columns and also
multiple functions to the same column
but we end up using is this AG function
for aggregate and we can pass a
dictionary applying the lot telling it
which column and which functions to
apply so let's say we want to see so
there's a user type in the Divi data sup
and you can subscribe or just be a
customer so anyone can go rent a bike or
you could actually Ave your membership
so we're saying let's say we want to see
the unique number of birth years by user
type and then we want to actually take
the mean and median trip duration by
each user type as well so here passing
this dictionary we're saying birth year
use this series unique function right
because we want to see the unique number
of birth years and for trip duration
since we want the mean and the median we
pass it a list right so it's going to
apply both these functions to this trip
duration field when we get back is this
nice kind of structure showing us the
information that we kind of wanted in
return does that make sense okay cool um
and then this is kind of the last part
I'm going to get into one of the awesome
things about panas is that there's this
nice image plotting integration with
matplotlib matplotlib can be a little
bit frustrating to work with at times
especially if you need to do some a lot
of custom things my view at this point
would be if you're doing a lot of like
visualization maybe look at something
like Seabourn if you you know if you're
wanting to change the colors of your
visualization all that but there's a
great talk Rob story gave at PI data and
Silicon Valley I think was last last
year I think was called up and down the
Python visualization stack and really he
goes through a whole group of library of
visualization libraries for Python and
kind of talks about which ones are good
when so I would recommend checking that
out in the demo notebook there's I have
a link to his slides in the video
actually so here your group we're going
to group by the start hour and we're
just calling size so this is that same
series that we looked at the first
example the number
trips by each star tower and we can
actually just call dot plot on it and
here I'm just passing in the figure size
because I want it to the visualizations
to be big so you guys can see them so we
got what we get back is just this pen is
kind of knows how to plot this already
for us so we can see it's very noisy a
little bit here so but in the week
during the the middle of the weeks we
see that there's a little bit more noise
because people aren't writing duty bikes
as much during the middle of the week
it tends to be a weekend thing mainly
because there are a lot more tourists in
Chicago on the weekends so now if we
wanted to see the distribution of trip
duration we can actually just take the
series so divvy now we're get we're
accessing that series trip duration and
we're getting a histogram if we just
plot the histogram then we're going to
bin it to a thousand bins we get this
nice histogram when we could see that
you know it looks like some sort of a
log normal distribution here and there
are a lot of rides that have are super
long and actually I'll it I used I
limited the access a bit because this
would have gone on and you wouldn't have
been able to see this nice kind of curve
that goes out even long tails now let's
say we wanted to see the percentage of
divvy rides that are less than twenty
minutes or the percentage that are less
than twenty minutes so if you think
about it's a cumulative distribution
function here so we want to see you know
all the divvy rides what percentage is
less than ten minutes this can be a
little bit goofy to do so if anyone
actually knows a better way to do this I
would love to talk to them after so here
we're going to take that the trip
duration and we're going to get the
value counts again and we're going to
store that series into a new object
which we're going to call duration
counts and then here again we're not
treating an indexes in a column we want
to name the index seconds and we want to
name the column like so that the values
of that series trips so here's what the
objects going to look like after we're
done with it we could see that the index
is named seconds and what the index
actually is now again it's it's the
number of seconds for that trip so we
can see that there are 712 trips where
it's 408 seconds okay I don't want to
work with an index here because we need
to kind of get
rolling some of the percentage right
because we're getting the cumulative
distribution so we need to get a bowling
some of the of the of the percentage so
we need to reset the index and create a
data frame so let me run this so we
could actually get this and I'll show
you guys what this looks like so DF HUD
we could see you know here's our we have
a data frame again right so we've reset
the index we could see out there are
seconds and trips yes just save it on
frame okay so be a little frame and then
your name cool thank you so so now we
have our our data frame and we want to
create a new column called minutes so
we're going to take the second column
where we have to divide it by 60 right
so if we run this and we set it back to
minutes so now we're going to have this
object data frame head and it's going to
give us the number so we've reset the
end we've set the index to minutes
because when you plot with pandas the
index is going to plot along the x-axis
so we want to look at the distribution
so we need the minutes along the x-axis
so we have seconds and trips and now
what we end up doing is for every series
we can call a cumulative sum function so
this is going to give us the rolling sum
so up here if we were to do let's do
let's just show how this works
if we were to call the cumulative sum on
trips trips we can see it's kind of it's
a rolling sum of every object before it
and finally when we get to the end this
should be the length of this series
right so we applied this cumulative sum
function and then we apply the total
number of trips in the data set or we
divided by the total number of data sets
in the trip to create a percentage right
so up here it's 68 divided by seven
hundred and sixty thousand to create the
percentage and we can actually I'm
putting it in parentheses here so this
is actually creating a series right
because when you divide a series by a
serial bot by a scalar or another series
you get a series back remember the thing
back early on when we talked about one
how when you're mapping you could just
apply you know you can add seven to it
you're just applying seven to everything
in the data
so here we're doing a little bit of math
and we're keeping the new series then we
can just call plot on it we can see this
nice cumulative distribution here that
about you know 35% of the trips are less
than 10 minutes long and about 70% of
the trips or 20 minutes long there's a
whole variety of different ways that you
can actually use the plot method there's
this kind parameter that'll show you
kind of differing plots so here let's
say we wanted to see the number of trips
taken by each Berthier we're going to do
it using a horizontal bar chart so here
we could say you know there ton of
people that were born in 85 that take
trips there were not so many people that
were born in 70 and if we go all the way
down there even some people that were
like 1930 there's one person in 19th
that was born in 1930 that's taking a
trip here we're going back to lambda
functions again and I just want to show
this actually I'm going to skip this one
because I'm going to use it again here
later on so here we want to see the we
want to start comparing men versus women
how do they take trips so here we're
using the supply function again and
because start date or our start hour is
a day time field we're calling a lambda
function and just extracting the date
then we're going to create a new field
called start date so again here we're
not looping we're just vectorizing the
operation by applying another function
to it and so we're going to group by
start date and gender call the size and
now we can see that this data frame is
it's we kind of have we have an index of
the start date and there's this
multi-level index the secondary index
here of the gender oh so here I'm
extracting the date so this start our
field is a date time I just want the
date so I'm creating a new start date
field that make sense I'm happy to talk
about it after why
via miss Wainwright can they muster all
right let's go this way can you talk
about it after I think I'm running close
to time actually here so the last thing
so if you actually do this we can
actually see since we want we're going
to want to plot this by men and women we
need we're going to need two columns one
for men one for women so we can actually
unstack the the index so what happens
let me run this so I could actually
unstack it but so what happens when you
unstack it is instead of having this
multi level index we've now tilted that
that one that first love sorry that's
second level of the index and created
columns out of it so now you know it's
equal if you were to do this you're
going to have to do this count if gender
equals male and then apply some logic
count if gender equals female do some
rolling some aggregation here we can
actually just say group I start date
gender size and since we know that the
gender is the second level of the index
you know Python it's zero based zero
based numbers so we could actually just
say on stack that second level which is
what one here and then show us the the
first five so here now we have these two
nice columns that are female and male
and if we were to call plot on it it's
going to graph it nicely for us so now
we can see that you know a lot of the
trips are taken by men and there aren't
so many trips that are taken by women
similarly we can do the same thing with
subscribers actually and the plot method
has when you're doing a group by plot
like this it has there's this nice
subplots that we can just pass true so
now we can see consumer and subscriber
and we actually get two nice plots here
for us so that we can compare them and
they don't necessarily have to be on the
same graph and then lastly we're going
to do a little bit more stuff to to kind
of get into unstacking so here we're
going to create we want to extract the
day of the week from the start time so
we're creating weekdays a series of
weekdays and then a series of hours so
again we're extracting the hour we're
going to group by the weekdays and the
hours and we want to count of the trips
so here we're naming it and uh we're
going to create we're going to have to
we're going to create a data frame out
of it so if we actually run this we can
see that I should have printed this data
frame we can see
weekday week today our we see so we get
the weekday on the first level of the
index and then the hour on the second
level of the index we're going to
unstack the first level because we want
to kind of look at it by weekday so if
we actually well I'll show you what the
unstack 0
I'll close my parentheses so we can now
we get this kind of matrix like
structure that has the weekday along the
top and 0 I think in Python is Monday
and allow the hours along the side and
if we actually just go here and take
this unstack data structure and call
plot on it we're going to get a nice
plot like this so we could actually see
over the weekend people are writing in
the middle of the day a lot more often
than during the week and we see these
spikes at about 8 o'clock and 5 o'clock
that show people are taking Divi for
their commutes it's kind of all I have
right now thanks everyone for listening
to me talk for that amount of time but
I'd love to take questions or chat a
little bit more if anyone has anything